i used to go to an atm machine and just
put my card in and say print balance
and just look at it and he's like i
would just do that like every day
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
[Music]
so we have an interview with
microacquire uh they
well we talk all about it then and and
it's within
it's with andrew he um he sells startups
basically on microacquire it's a
marketplace for selling startups but
we're gonna talk about some ideas first
and catch up
i uh i've hired someone jake mcdonald to
do research
i just sent you you of course hired like
a guy who looks like an
a football player uh and yet he's your
like business researcher guy
so here's the here's the secret which is
uh sean has had
a little bit of help with research for a
very long time
and he uh his name's ben we've talked
about ben ben's amazing
and i got jealous and i said i want to
ben so i went and hired a ben and his
name is jake i had been
or had jake call ben to get all of his
research tips
and ben did a really good job and i just
sent to you sean
my notion doc with all jake's stuff it's
good right you see how we organize
very thorough yeah he's he's wonderful
so uh now we're gonna we're gonna be a
little bit more well researched although
he doesn't start technically kind of
till next week this is kind of
we're still kind of getting used to
things trainer wheels yeah all right uh
cool
yeah so basically we're gonna do a
couple ideas now and then andrew's gonna
join andrew is the founder of
microacquire
which is zillow for buying and selling
companies so
we bought one company on there uh i
bought a basically
we bought it me and andrew bought a
business for for this kid uh who's like
a college senior we bought we bought him
a business to go run
um just as an experiment and that was
kind of the first time i used it so i
think it's pretty cool
he's to tell us about like his previous
company which he sold for
tens of millions uh how that deal came
about how he structured it
um what he did with the money so we were
like all right if you're gonna come on
you gotta tell us
what he did what'd you do with the money
so he tells us about what he bought how
he invests
money his kind of like very boring
investment strategy and why he chooses
to do that
um so yeah we're going to talk about
that with andrew but first
a couple ideas all right so i want to
talk about this tweet i saw
and it's a tweet from doug ludlow you
know who that is
yeah main street yeah ceo of main street
founder main street and so he tweeted
this thing out he goes
isn't it crazy that bubba gump shrimp
the restaurant chain
does like 200 300 million dollars a year
in revenue
um when forrest gump the movie that the
brand is based on
did like 700 million like lifetime box
office so he's like the restaurant
is that real restaurant has produced
more money than forrest gump
ever did and i was like that's
interesting he's like why aren't there
more of these and so i kind of like this
idea which is basically
you take uh ip intellectual property
a brand from tv or movies and you
license it so they did this for
um for public shrimp company and so what
i went and kind of looked up the
backstory of this and the backstory is
pretty simple it's like
um the movie happens and paramount is
actually the one who did this
i thought i just kind of figured that
some entrepreneur went to them and got
the brand actually was the opposite so
from what i could read or what i found
paramount pictures goes and approaches
this restaurant group called rusty
pelican and they're like hey
we want you to create a brand based off
the brand of the movie because it's like
a kind of a key
plot point in the movie or whatever it's
a key moment in the movie and um and so
some crazy things about this so first
they do that uh it it generates you know
200 million plus a year it gets
it got bought by the fertittas i think
um and their their restaurant group
but it um this is also where you know
the actor chris pratt
of course he was a waiter at bubblegum
shrimp company and this is how he got
discovered he was waiting on a table for
this producer this is this director
producer lady
and he's like oh i love that thing you
made and she's like oh that's great blah
blah blah and they're talking and she's
like you know what like
you know you want to be an actor he's
like yeah that's what i'm just waiting
tables i want to be an actor
and that's how he got his break in the
movie industry also how did you learn
about this
uh just a hell of a lot of googling my
friend we don't all have
buff researchers like jake so some of us
gotta get our hands dirty and go do some
good so
let me tell you something real quick so
do you know so you said the fertittas
you met you were referring to the
fertitta brothers right so there's two
brothers
is the cousin yeah so i think he's like
a distance cousin so i was gonna i was
gonna correct you but
you you know the story but tillman so
there's this guy named tillman fertitta
so a lot of people probably don't know
this if you live in houston if you live
in texas you
certainly know who this guy is he's a
pretty um
he's a pretty polarizing figure i think
a lot of people who know him think he's
a huge [__] he probably he probably
is an [__] i mean he's pretty cut
through
he owns uh this thing called landry's
landry's i i've never even been to one i
think that's its own restaurant
yeah it's like a steak caps i think but
then he also owns bubba gump shrimps he
owns uh
uh i believe like jay alexander's ruth
chris steakhouse
like a ton of like 30 to 50 ahead dinner
places so like
not particularly fancy but upscale
really upsell
uh upscale franchises and he owns about
600 of them but here's a fun fact
i am pretty positive uh that
landry's is the largest company in
america
that is owned by one person uh tillman
fertitta
owns 100 of the business he owns
literally every single share
uh right around the beginning of covid
they were doing something like 5 billion
in revenue and like 1.5 to 2 billion in
ebitda that's nuts by the way he owns
the houston rockets now so that's
why that's how he got a lot more famous
was because when you buy the rockets
people want to know who the heck this
guy is
um so that's kind of crazy okay so so so
back to kind of this idea real quick so
a licensing ip so doug was basically
saying he's like why don't more people
do this and he's like why isn't there a
paper company that's like the dunder
mifflin paper company
or and you know and so there's a couple
of these so i went through and i kind of
came up with a list
of brands that i think could translate
here's here's my list and then you tell
me what you would do
if you were approaching this or if you
think this is a bad idea you can tell me
i don't think it's a bad idea that's for
sure here's my top five
top five brands that i think you could
license a creative company so dunder
mifflin paper company yes the office is
one of the most popular shows of all
time
it has like crazy reruns on netflix uh
and there's no signature paper companies
what what is another paper company i
have no idea so i think you'd stand out
all right duff beer from the simpsons i
think duff beer could be a real beer
maybe is a real beer somewhere uh but i
think duff beer is
a potential one you don't have too many
more uh you don't have another decade or
two left with that one though
yeah yeah that one's sort of aging out
uh wonka bars so anything with willy
wonka
i think you could i think willy wonka
painted this picture of like wonderment
around the factory and this innovative
stuff so i think you could take that
brand and create
cool novel like chocolates and candies
out of it
um another one is if you're an ad agency
could you go
and actually like franchise or license
the mad men
uh brand for for that so basically
sterling cooper draper or whatever it is
jay for price say the name of their
agency um
you know why not why not use that if
you're gonna start an ad agency versus
anything else
um and then i started thinking about all
right where else would i go for this
and i think the opportunity here is like
depending on what age bracket you go for
but i think the 90s had a bunch
of uh brands that were famous in the 90s
for our age group if you're
basically 30 or 40 right now there's a
bunch of brands that have like zero kind
of like equity value anymore
but the brand names you grew up with it
so you just so it still means something
to you
and so we've talked about like warheads
or jinko jeans
yeah like a bunch of these brands and i
think the move here i think one
interesting play here would be
you don't actually have to create the
product you could create
so so another idea is to create the
nostalgia licensing company
and all it does is it goes and buys
options on
these brands and then it pedals them to
existing makers of products
and it just says hey why don't you use
we have this portfolio of nostalgic
brands
you could choose one of these that fits
kind of your product category or
whatever and you could just be the
middleman
basically you buy up buy cheap options
on these brands and then you sell them
at a kind of a retail price if you can
and even if you get one or two hits i
think the business could be quite
profitable so that's my random ass
licensing idea i went to urban
outfitters the other day because there's
one near my house
and they had they had you know urban
alfred is pretty shitty but they have
like tons of old t-shirts
and they it's like their their whole
genre of t-shirts was
things that 30 year olds saw their dads
wear
and and it was like t-shirts ahead like
the old
coors light logo the old budweiser logo
i forget some of the other logos but
like i
pretty remember blind skateboards or
world industry skateboards or
independent skateboarding
it kind of like transcended a popular
culture i thought but they had a lot of
those things um but anyway i'm on board
that's amazing that bubblegum trip does
that much revenue who
and it's it's still owned by landry's i
guess but dude it's a
horrible restaurant i'm amazed at that
it's like it's like an applebee's
yeah well dude one of my first investors
of any business i ever had was this guy
who owned 12 applebee's and this guy was
like
you know i went to college at duke in
durham which is a very pretty small city
and this guy was like one of the
wealthiest guys in durham and how he
owned like i don't know 10 to 20
applebee's and i was like
oh you could just do that and he's like
yeah here's how it works
i was like don't even tell me i i i
don't i want to be more successful than
you
but i don't care i'm less successful
than you is what i mean i just don't
want to own 20 applebee's like that
can't be the end game here
i had a friend who worked on their ad
agency or his ad agency won that account
applebee's and they gave him a thousand
dollars to go spend at applebee's and
told him like to bring a friend and
order just a ton of stuff so you
understand it
and we ordered everything
and i'm a slob i eat anything and i'll
eat a ton of food like
six months of food yeah i'm an animal
and he ordered we ordered
so much stuff and i eat everything and
anything
and i got it in front of my plate and i
was like you guys just microwaved the
steak
like this is a microwave it was
[__] awful
yeah uh what do you want to talk about i
just had one cool thing which was i
don't know if you saw i tweeted this out
yesterday
but there's a video of jeff bezo so i i
thought this billionaire going to space
it's like elon's doing it and then you
know uh
jeff bezos starts blue origin and
richard branson has virgin galactic and
it's sort of like oh okay cool like
this is you know golf for you know old
white billionaires basically it's like
this is
something that they're playing it's just
a dick measuring contest is what it is
yeah it's a thing-swinging thing and so
and so i was like all right well
as i kind of wrote it off i was like you
know i think elon was in it you know
sort of
first and genuinely for for a bunch of
reasons um
that seemed real to me but you know
definitely there's an ego component to
it
but what was cool was i found this
interview with jeff bezos
from to the year 2000 so 21 years ago
and amazon at this time was like six
years old so
it was definitely a thing but it wasn't
amazon like today
it was like you know it was a public
company but it wasn't
uh it wasn't it wasn't a juggernaut like
it is now and i think they probably only
had a couple of categories at that point
there wasn't like
prime and doing video and doing all this
other stuff
and he's sitting down and they're like
you know so so you know what what would
you want to do
you know what would you do if you could
do anything he's like if i could do
anything
yeah he's like you know i would love to
explore space like space he's like yeah
i would love to just explore space
and you know he's like you know the
space and they're like well
maybe you could do it someday yeah
you're a smart guy but if you put your
mind to it he's like well it's hard
it's really hard like but i think you
could do it and he's
like yeah you know it's harder than you
think like we haven't made much
progress for space and like in the last
20 years you know
but the technology is like he's like
maybe 20 years from now the technology
will be there or maybe we could
we could do it and then 21 years sort of
to the day
he's in a spaceship going you know in
his own rocket company going into outer
space
uh so i thought that was pretty cool it
made me give i had a different
level of respect for it because it's
more like somebody having a vision and a
dream
20 years ago when it wasn't cool to talk
about it or say it
and then actualizing it not just sort of
like copycatting elon
yeah so look i think that it is like a
like a like a measuring contest a
pissing match
but i'm all and at first you're like
well that's lame these guys are so rich
why don't you do something good
but my opinion is this is good it's just
so long-term thinking that it's actually
hard to see but i do think that we're
going to get good out of this
and my opinion is when when rich people
want to give money
and they want [__] named after them like
a building like a hospital wing
or they want to go to space and make a
big deal out of it and then like maybe
in 10 years we can capture some of that
value of like all right they kind of
paved the way
at first a lot of people are like well
that's [__] you know [__] these guys
but i'm like who gives a [__] that's
such that's the that's the most fair
trade on earth
we named this building after you and you
give us all this money
hey i wrote your name on this yeah great
thanks for the 100 mil
yes it's like dude let them have that
who cares if they have an ego like you
get the money
so like in my opinion uh we should
accept it as
as good although for sure bezos said
something kind of stupid the other day
although i do like that he said it
because it was kind of funny
but yeah but at the same time i'm like
oh
you are asking for it so adam that's not
a great move so bezos flew up to space
with his brother and this older woman
i forget her name and a young kid i
believe there was supposed to be another
person on there
but he had a scheduling conflict uh i
swear to god
that guy he had there's supposed to be
someone else and there was a scheduling
conflict so the guy couldn't make it
and they go to space and they're up
there throwing skittles at each other's
face did you see that they're like doing
flips
bezos he's like he goes hey guys i
brought skittles and he
brings out a packet of skittles and he
throws a skittle out one person he goes
and the guy catches it in your mouth and
you go and jeff goes let me try and jeff
hands the kid the bag of skittles he
goes
throw one in my mouth and i thought that
was kind of funny amazing amazing for
skittles i'm surprised he's not like hey
i have amazon sugar circles yeah you
know i'm throwing
at each other you know like our own
house brand so i thought that was kind
of cute funny and he lands
and he says i just want to thank all of
you workers at amazon
as well as all you customers because you
paid for this
and he's he said that and i was like
that's not the best way to phrase that
then this morning i i shared this with
you i saw a business insider article
which i think is i kind of love them but
at the same time i
i i can't stand some of those things
they write but uh jeff bezos
was actually an early investor in
business insider and the business
insider article
uh was written in such a way that it's
uh
it was complaining about it and it said
uh um
bezos's flight to space was too
cramped and far too short uh oh my god
and i was like oh my god you're
completely like
okay a couple thoughts on what you just
said that was amazing first of all
the couple thoughts on what you just
said i
hate the haters uh okay first of all dan
just looked it up the person who had the
scheduling conflict paid 28 million for
their seat
so that's kind of insane i think their
dad paid for their seat or something
look up this story dan tell me what what
i'm missing here because
wow you know how if you're gonna hate
someone don't hate the billionaire who
built amazon
and then reinvested his money into like
exploring outer space
hate the trust fund kid who paid 28
million for his ticket and then
and then no showed because he you know
was doing a tick tock dance or something
like i don't know who i don't know the
story behind this but that's kind of
ridiculous
the um i'm so tired of people just like
hating billionaires randomly i'm team
billionaire is what i'm trying to say
um you know people are so dumb they're
like why are you wasting money on this
do you know when they like do this like
when you pay for when you when you
fund a space company you're paying you
know that money doesn't just like go
into space and just
vanish yeah i think has like 3 000
employees i think
when he spends the money it's going into
people's pockets and so it's funding
jobs it's funding
you know um expert technology
development and a lot of great
technology we have
came because of what nasa did for the
space program and so
you know one of the silliest things is
thinking that the money just somehow
gets vacuumed into outer space
the second thing is just don't be that
guy it's not even that i'm team
billionaire i'm team
not the guy who's hating on billionaires
all the time um
this happened actually a second ago
clubhouse tweeted out
oh like we are open for everybody now
there's no waitlist or something like
that we got a new logo and all this
stuff
and you know i'm i'm obviously not you
know the clubhouse cheerleader right so
so
don't get me wrong but the very first
comment the top comment is
uh open for everybody but you don't even
have captions on the live audio
so it's not open for deaf people and i'm
like okay like
you know fair point that it's you know
it doesn't have like full accessibility
but like
that's the top comment that's the first
comment like
this company has to provide you live
audio text captioning
otherwise like [__] them like it's just
the
hater culture is so annoying to me
and it's so weak and spineless to be
just like a you know like the top
comment just like
oh yeah you did this great thing but uh
you know but whatever and i know that's
gonna sound hypocritical because i wrote
kind of like a giant thread
hating on clubhouse um well it wasn't
exactly hating
but that's gonna be the easy criticism i
wasn't trying to hate i was basically
saying what i think some of the like why
i think they're not gonna
why it's not gonna work out the way they
think some of the like strategic product
problems i just wrapped it in a funny
even though you
you explicitly said i hope none of this
comes true yeah i wanted to win i think
it's cool when things win but like
you know i think people are missing the
boat um anyways i guess i'm just over
hater culture and
the easiest way to find it is go read
any like response to anything that
elon or jeff bezos or these people like
people who are doing great things in the
world
and have won the game uh you know the
money game
they attract this like really annoying
class of haters
and i'd actually think you should
rephrase it i'm not team billionaire
what i'm team is i'm on team people who
who set audacious goals and get after it
do your thing if that's your thing do
your thing and let me
let you do your thing i'm gonna do my
thing why why do i need to worry about
your thing
yeah i have respect for someone who says
they're going to write a book this year
and they write a book or someone who
says they're going to lose 50 pounds and
they lose 50 pounds
yeah i'm on team you set what you're
going to do and you actually achieve it
and it just so happens
that one of the big outputs of uh
business is money and that's a great way
to measure it but
when i look at something like uh sean
parker before he got involved with
facebook and before he actually became
wealthy sean parker
started napster napster uh a lot of
people well
and it probably was the case it was
unethical and he actually it was a
it he did not succeed financially
because of it i've always admired that
because it was an 18 year old
who just revolutionized something and
totally caused a [__] storm
and got in the thick of it and made
something interesting and so i'm in
favor of people who do that and
oftentimes those are people who build a
hundred thousand person company called
amazon but
yeah so i i would actually say if you
are a billionaire hater out there
i think you should actually rephrase it
i mean there are people who are
billionaires that i think are
[__] awful people and i don't want
them to exist but
i enjoy seeing people who put their
their stamp on the world and i think
that's what we should celebrate not just
defaulting to hate
uh the way some people do yeah or you
know it's just in general like how
somebody else spends their money
that's their that's their that's their
business right like i think elon right
now is living in like a 50 square foot
like
pop-up house or something you've seen
this he's living in like a shipping
container or something he sold his house
he sold his cars
he's living in a goddamn like 50 square
foot shipping container
and he uses all you know he put his
entire
like he whatever he made out of zip he
put all he poured it
all in went into debt to try to make
tesla and spacex happen
and like when they win you know he gets
rewarded for it but even if
he decided to do nothing and never work
again and just wanted mansions and
butlers
cool that's is your money do your thing
um
decide you know criticizing other people
for how they spend their money
really all that says i wouldn't spend my
money that way and i think that's a fair
thing to say
but i think in most cases the people who
are doing this they would do they would
spend their money you know
in the same ways or worse and for the
record if i could if i could trade spots
with elon musk if someone said you could
trade spots automatically and by the way
you'll still be the same age that you
are
i wouldn't i wouldn't do it yeah not a
million years would i trade spots with
that guy but i think it's awesome what
he's doing for him good do your thing
uh all right uh here's something on the
opposite end of the spectrum have you
ever heard of bill's lemonade
no all right so go to this website just
type in bills lemonade
this is a little fascinating business a
friend kind of tipped me off to this
and um i can't say their name because i
don't know if they want their name said
but
basically this is this is a uh bill
didn't tell me
this is like a business and a box and
this business does about five million a
year
roughly and what they do is they just
sell you a
kind of like a course and the materials
to start your own lemonade stand
not for kids but for like adults like
you could start this outside of a
of a concert venue or a ball game or
like at your like
local like neighborhood square or
whatever and what they do is they
basically say hey
you can you can here's a business in a
box if you have the ability to grab this
bottle and shake it
you can become a lemonade stand owner
and you can make this much money here's
how it works then you can download their
like little brochure which shows the
unit economics it's like every lemonade
costs a dollar twenty to make
that's your cost and you're gonna sell
that for you know four dollars five
dollars six dollars depending on your
location so you're going to have you
know 70
margins on this thing and if you could
sell x many per day you're gonna make
this much money
and they basically just sell you this
business in a box um
it's a very simple business and builds
lemonade on the other side they don't
take any
royalties or franchise fees they say
you're gonna get our brand we're going
to send
or send you the machine the frozen you
know lemonade machine the shakers the
the cups the everything and uh all you
do is you pay for the materials and the
like information the course on how to do
it
and i just thought this is kind of a
fascinating idea and i feel like you
could do this for
a whole bunch of other a whole bunch of
other like industries as well like
whether it's
you know snow cones or ice cream trucks
or
pest control or something like that like
i just feel like there's a whole bunch
of business boxes you could make
and if you did that maybe you could even
roll these up into one
thing which is like hey you don't want a
job you want your own business it's
going to get you
a hundred thousand dollars a year and
you'll be able to kind of control the
hours you work and you're going to work
for yourself
are there people out there who want that
trade as a franchisee yes and then
basically you just say great
would you like the lemonade one would
you like to drive an ice cream truck
would you like to do this
or that and we own all these brands it's
sort of like what 1 800 got junk has
where they have the
the trucks you can drive the franchise
you could buy to be a junk hauler
or the house painter or that i forgot
they have like three or four of them but
i feel like you could create a a mini
version of what a hunter got junk with
this
dude this is awesome i'm looking at this
and i'm trying to find
um there was a guy when i started my
hot dog stand there was a guy in
tennessee who was doing this exact same
things for hot dog stand so you'd give
him five grand and he would send you
everything you needed
along with the state rules and things
like that i need it for hot dog stands
bill's lemonade is better because you
could spend
i don't even know what the price is like
a couple hundred dollars on here and i'm
looking at it now this is pretty badass
you uh and these guys have been doing
this forever by the way i'm looking at
their website i've seen this brand a
long time ago yeah
this is badass and they just have like
you can buy all your supplies from there
i recognize these cups too by the way
right i've seen the second thing at
baseball games or something but yeah so
i think this is kind of interesting
another version of this i think you
could do is in the services industry
and so like here's like another one
which is like let's say
um corporate headshots so i once saw
facebook ads and the profile picture i
have for this podcast that's like kind
of like
when i'm trying to make this like
ominous look it's because i saw a
facebook
ad of a really high quality headshot
and a like a striking headshot and it
was like
i can make i can take a photo of you
that will look like this
like you can level up your kind of like
game as far as your brand your linkedin
your website
whatever it is um you know it's 300
bucks
and like i shoot in you know in the bay
area and i i'll come do
a shoot for you and you get to pick your
photos whatever and i just remember
thinking oh that's really smart like
i've never seen facebook ads this is
somebody i've never seen a photographer
doing facebook ads for this but i feel
like you could do the same thing here
where you could basically sell somebody
a business in a box that says hey
um maybe maybe photos a little too high
skill but you could say like
any kind of like service and you could
say great
um you're going to be the service
provider in your local area
and i'm going to run the facebook ads
countrywide and then whenever there's a
lead for your area i'm just going to
dispatch it to you and you just go
fulfill it and it's a business in a box
that way
great you wear you wear our uniform you
know you could do geek squad this way
like tech help or something like that
um you could do it for the thing we
talked about with like setting up home
uh uh home office and homes like office
video studios what i would do is i would
do it for taking
so when we when i rented out my place so
i took pictures and i put it online and
i didn't get that much love
and then i i went online and i found a
photographer to come and take pictures
for me and i paid her 200
and i got way more uh traction
and my wife works at airbnb and i think
she has told me i don't remember if
uh who told me of i think it was her
that told me that
the number one uh difference between a
winning airbnb and a losing airbnb is
the pictures
and yeah i definitely think you could
have airbnb photos.com or whatever it is
and that and you take 25 for every lead
that you send
a photographer and you could totally
crush it that way right
um so i like these little business of
the box ideas this is like you know the
opposite of the billionaire space race
this is the
bill's lemonade making five million
dollars selling lemonade kits to people
which is just cool
there was this company called i cracked
icracked was started by a friend of mine
aj forsyth it went out
either it was acquired but uh i don't
think they even kept the brain anymore
and what they did was
they actually raised like 20 million or
30 million dollars from addressing
horowitz
and what icracked did was they were
doing this for
iphone repair and so i guess to switch a
an iphone screen on your phone it takes
only like a few hours of training uh
anyone could figure it out
if i just showed you how to do it and
what they would do is they would send
you leads and they would take a small
cut of the charge so they would charge
like 150
to fix your phone and maybe they would
take 20 then in order to get leads from
them you had to buy iphone parts from
them
and they would sell you iphone parts and
they were doing something like 30
million dollars a year in ecom
sales i don't know how much service
revenue they're making but just selling
right
screens they're doing like 20 or 30
million dollars in sales for the service
yeah that's crazy what do you think went
wrong with the business uh
i think they raised too much money and
probably spent way too much money on ads
i'm not sure if it was quite venture
scale uh they
got to like 20 or 30 million in sales
and i don't know if they could figure
out
how to get bigger than that and they try
to launch more stuff and probably lost
focus
good gotcha but there's other services
out there that are just like them
that do like 30 40 50 million dollars a
year in revenue
also aj my friend who's the founder he's
a wild man and i think that he had like
crazy aspirations of like having a drone
come and drop off stuff
uh like things like that and i don't
know if that industry is cut out for
that but i do think you could have a
nice company that makes 30 or 40 in
sales
oh this episode of visionary's gone
wrong he had a healthy business and
wanted to
change it to having drones drop off your
iphone yeah
he was also the one who like paddle
boards to work every day or something
right like doesn't he do something crazy
like that
yeah he had a small little dinghy boat
like a little tiny bow
i forget what they called it but it was
it was it's super small like uh
the small like the size of like a little
baby desk but had like an engine on it
and he would ride that from where's the
oracle office out there
uh like 20 minutes away uh i forget in
california but
he would write it down the bay to his
office uh at south park in soma
yeah i think that's awesome uh sounds
like a super interesting guy i love it
yeah he's crazy um all right so do are
we gonna get to the episode or the yeah
let's do the interview now all right so
you're gonna hear uh
andrew and uh let us know what you think
andrew
so how do you pronounce your last name
gazdecki
my friends call me gas gas all right go
ahead sean sorry
i never had a cool nickname or friends
for that matter but um
all right so you did that you did your
like micro acquire
uh funding announcement thing yesterday
i'm curious does that do anything so
you know we're seeing this a lot more
where it's like all the famous people on
twitter and tech
like did something they also promoting
something me and sam have been a part of
a few of these
um what's the result is that like
meaningful or is it just like a
feel-good moment or does it do anything
for you
yeah that's a good question i would i
would say both i mean
really you know the goal of that
fundraise was i want to build
microcore with a starter community and
so just having everyone
involved in that for feedback and just
you know really letting everybody know
that this is kind of
you know something to watch um so
good brand value added and then yeah we
saw like 2.5 million
impressions on twitter so uh for those
listening
micro acquire so andrew you've had a
couple companies you sold one recently
or like a couple years ago which was it
sounds like a home run for you
but micro acquire although you guys have
some really big aspirations
right now if we had to like kind of dumb
it down it's a newsletter that people
pay to get access to and that
uh content is interesting startups that
you've vetted and are now for sale
that's like the current iteration right
well it's not just a newsletter right
like i go to the website i don't get the
i don't even look at the newsletter it's
so it's a market it's like a marketplace
it's like if you want to go buy a house
you go to zillow you see a bunch of
houses for sale
i only read the newsletter okay
who's who's the normal user is it sam or
me
uh it sounds like you sean so it's a
marketplace so
you can sign up create a profile list
your startup
in you know literally minutes then i
have a team on the back end that
basically creates like a sim completely
free
we have a streamlined process that does
that and then
once you go live for people who don't
know it's basically a document that
outlines
basic details that buyers would want to
know like revenue
how much time are you spending on
customer support what is the tech stack
who are your competitors
um why are you selling asking price
market opportunity
just basically a pitch deck but more
geared towards like i'm selling the
business
and uh after you go live on micro
acquire you thousand
uh dollars worth of subscribers so they
pay
like 299 dollars a year right
yeah 290. uh we're like 675
1000. okay and so the i mean you have
this grand vision here but in doing this
you i mean there's a what did you
describe it did you say zillow for
startups is that how you described it
once
zillow framing a basically what we
wanted to build
yeah so what we want to build is we want
to build a global
and modern m a marketplace um right now
the whole
m a marketplace is fragmented
and we're looking to consolidate it and
really
bring in everyone who's involved in ma
transactions
like when you get on the larger side you
know you have investment bankers you
haven't
m a advisor on the lower end you have
business brokers
um even just people for due diligence
or accounting or you know potential
wealth management if you're successful
in your acquisition
so we're going to be really building a
community of advisors that startups can
hire but then on top of that we're going
to build tools to make
acquisitions super easy we we bought a
business
for somebody on here so we did a what we
called a micro spec
which is basically uh your idea andrew
you basically
tweeted it at me or something like that
and i was like this is a great idea
what we did was we said hey let's put up
five grand and um
into a holding of blank shell company so
we put give five grand to an
entrepreneur
and then we'll find them a business to
buy on microacquire we'll go vet 50
deals 100 deals and we'll go find a
business for them to buy and we'll go
buy a micro business
and then other people thought that was
such a cool idea that somebody was like
oh i'm in for five i'm in for five i'm
in
f and all of a sudden we had a hundred
grand i think the the total amount was
like
85 to 100 grand that we ended up raising
from random people on twitter
uh to help this entrepreneur daniel buy
his first business
and said like he was going gonna go get
a job and then it's like okay instead
you can um you can buy this shopify app
that's producing revenue that's
profitable today
and uh and let's go go buy this thing
and so that's what we ended up doing
which i think is pretty cool and
that experiment is uh is still running
so the transaction closed he's
figuring out ways to grow it he's
sending his little like investor updates
it's awesome and
i feel i i called it at the time i said
this is like when you go to buy like
cake mix and it's like just add water
this is a like just add hustle here's a
business it's here's the code's already
written the business already running the
revenue's already there
and all you need to do is grow it and
you just need to add that hustle in to
to grow this thing
yeah and we did we actually did one with
the hustle
and we gave and we did the same thing i
don't remember who came first but we did
the same thing
and the guy who won it is a dentist here
in new york and he's offering to give me
free braces as a thank you
do you need racism
yeah i'm still working with him on uh
finding a business he's um
he's being pretty picky but uh we'll get
we'll get something good but um
yeah he's good to be picky he was like
you want to come in for a teeth cleaning
retainer braces let me know i would love
to thank you
he's awesome we've been chatting um
almost weekly just going over businesses
he's interested in
i give my opinion and most of them are
like no
that one's like too complex or something
like that
um but sean i want to talk about that
that deal that we did
you have no [__] idea how much work
that was like
i literally had to get notarized like 50
emails come through
dude we did it legit um like
like you know we formed a new inc
so a new corporation to purchase and
transfer the assets into
uh we you know created stock agreements
for
20 plus investors so this was harder
than the fundraise that i
i just did by a mile and uh it
took like three weeks the legal bill for
me was like 15k
and i spent like 60 [__] hours
it was totally worth it um dan is
amazing i immediately
maybe it sounds sounds like it might not
be worth it well
well here's the thing is it opened my
eyes to
a new opportunity for microacquire as
well which is there's all these
amazing operators that don't have
capital but
again there's so many businesses on
microwave that you know they're built by
builders they aren't looking to scale
the business they're not familiar with
sales and marketing
and so we see an opportunity to
potentially allow them to
raise capital from other investors just
like we did with dan
like microspac specs are kind of getting
a bad name so we might need to rebrand
on that
um but yeah so like if you're if you're
like you own an
agency and you see a product for two
million bucks
and you have tens of thousands of
customers you can easily sell this
product to
we allow you to basically present that
to
other investors inside microwave and
this is just like a napkin idea this
isn't like a guaranteed thing
but streamlining that whole process that
we went through sean like that i think
could be
a really really interesting opportunity
and we're thinking about that a little
bit
by the way the the thing you're
describing is like it's basically what
angelus did so angelus was like great
we're a marketplace to connect
uh startups and investors and they
started by doing that
and then they were like okay cool what
else can we do well startups need
employees so
we'll create a jobs division and then
they're like well some of these
entrepreneurs want to be investors
but they're not investors they don't
have the ability to raise capital you
know it's very hard to raise a fund okay
we'll create like rolling funds and
we'll create spvs it will create
one-click ways for now you to invest
instead of just being
an entrepreneur and so they created
what's called a market network which is
basically
people have heard of a network network's
just a bunch of like let's say let's say
there's 10 dots on the screen and
they're connected by like little lines
that's a network
and all the dots do their own thing and
a market network is where
it's ten dots on a screen and there's
lines connecting all of them but there's
money signs going in between each
right so like on facebook you transfer
likes to each other you transfer
comments to each other messages
but on angel angellist when you hire
someone for a job you give them money
when you invest in somebody you give
them money when you uh raise money from
it for your rolling fund somebody's
giving you money and so there's
every transaction instead of just being
a message is money
and so if you've never heard this
concept before uh it's a pretty
important one and in terms of business
go research market networks james
courier and the nfx
team write a lot about this they're kind
of the only ones i see writing about
this
but i think it's a pretty important idea
and then once you know
oh there's such a thing as a market
network then when you see a business
that's structured as a market network
you know it's a good opportunity either
to start it or to invest in it that's
why i invested microquire because i was
like oh this is a
this is a market network great i've been
looking for market networks to invest in
this is a good one um yeah so i just
wanted to kind of throw that little
theory in if nobody knows that that term
and one of the reasons why we wanted you
to come on andrew was um
i want to hear about the micro acquire
story
but i want to hear particularly two
things in this order the first
is i want you to go through some of the
coolest
startups that you have sold or are
selling
on the platform some of the insights
that you've gotten from them
and and and things like that and then
also what we should talk about at the
end is you sold your last company for
like
20 uh maybe 30 or 40 million dollars i
forget the exact amount like a
a pretty significant amount and
life-changing amount and you
you you told me some crazy stuff that
you did with the money i would
definitely want to talk about that
but can we start with that one i want to
i want to hear that one so yeah
so before micro car you start a company
you sell it for ball parkish give me a
range uh or rhymes with
30 million how do you describe this
let's just assume i have
you know low eight figures i
i candidly don't like to specifically
say
how much i sold my company for i think
it's a weird flex and
it's hard to do without feeling like
you're bragging so
let's just peg it at low eight figures
but um
yeah the story there i started a company
in college i was 21
it was a no code app builder so it was a
sas company
uh only raised a hundred thousand
dollars for that business
ran it for about eight years grew it to
over 10 million in recurring revenue
employees was over a hundred
there's a lot of moving parts of that
business
um those people overseas
yeah so how do you have 100 employees or
you weren't making a lot of profit and
you're underpaying people
yeah so it was it was a mixture of both
not underpaying people but
we probably half the team was in-house
so our entire engineering team was
probably
overseas um but the way it started was
again i'm not a technical founder at all
i don't know to write code
at all and when i tell people that they
they're kind of like wait what
um but i was in chico and there's no
engineers in chico
but i just went on upwork i previously
had a job board before that that i also
sold and that was a seed money for
business apps but found just randomly
found
an engineer in china his name was
raymond chester i'm still friends with
him today and he was just
a badass like he could have been a cto
at
a silicon valley company and i
paid him well treated him well i
consider him like a brother
and considering i didn't know how to
hire other engineers or spot good
engineers i knew how to manage
and that's one tip for people that
aren't technical is
you know i always recommend don't learn
how to code learn how to
manage engineers properly
and so i ended up just hiring all his
friends so we ended up having like a
house for them and they had like 20
engineers in china and we had engineers
in
uh russia we had one and we had a group
we had a qa team in
the ukraine um
so you're a big big communist fan
i i guess you could say so i mean not
not by design but you know we
we did not discriminate yeah was your
customer service based out of cuba or
what
no no so customer service was in-house
but we did have 24 7 customer service so
we had some
customer support reps in brazil france
um some other some other areas but
all right so let's just fast forward to
the good bits so you
you build the business and it's good 10
million in recurring revenue
you you decide to sell it why did you
decide to sell it and then
how did you sell it um so i was
so initially i i tried selling it when i
was
26 i hired an investment bank and
this kind of leads into microwave as
well we did you know full road show
um ended up getting an offer for
30 million ended up turning turning down
that offer we also had an offer from a
strategic company
one of the you know big do yourself
website
companies you could probably guess it i
was young i felt i still had gas in the
tank
and so i wanted to push for you know a
larger exit
after we went through that process i
just kept running the business kept
growing the business kept staying
focused on
executing which is the number one way to
really sell a business is have a good
business so
went back to you know executing with my
team and then
uh just started getting tired that's the
short answer or just
you know managing that many people
monday comes around it's like hey can we
talk it's like
i get it like you wanna switch jobs like
please just
you can just email me like i'll write
your reference like i love you
like like please i don't need to hear
like you know we're good or like i'm
sick
you know it just became so much
management and
i love you know building businesses and
the
ideation stage the way the transaction
went down was
uh the private equity firm esw capital
had previously reached out to us
i think it was like five years ago or
something like that like prior to the
investment bank
and i know this because during due
diligence
we had to share all the ndas that we had
signed and i found them from usw capital
i was like oh
we've met before nice to meet you again
uh
you know let's uh let's see if we can
make this happen
they gave me fantastic terms it was an
all-cash transaction
uh we did a stock purchase so i
benefited from qsbs
which if you're looking to sell a
business look up qsbs you pay zero
federal taxes
on up to the first 10 million so i saved
i don't know what i saved i gotta ask my
accountant but um i actually didn't even
know about qsb as well
if you're i had qsbs if you're in
california
uh it's uh about 15 so 15
on 10 million you save 1.5 million
dollars or it might be even a little bit
more but around one and a half million
dollars in savings
no it's actually 20. i think it's more
20. so
i saved like 2 million on taxes and i
paid 13.
well yeah you're my bad i i'm an idiot i
totally i picked the wrong
the wrong one i forgive you sean
i i'm calling you the wrong name on
purpose man because you
butchered my name levels to that joke
got you back got you back um but anyways
um so we structured a really
favorable deal for me so we had two
million cash on hand which we added on
to the purchase price
so we had an agreed purchase price
and i said i want a stock deal
no earn out i'd love for you to buy the
cash and the reason for buying the cash
is they buy it um basically
they just put a 1x multiple on to the
purchase price and so
typically if you are required you have 2
million cash in the bank account that
is dividend back out to shareholders and
you're st you're taxed at
40 so we got qsbs on that 2 million cash
um quick transition in terms of me
leaving the business so i was out of the
business in 90 days
that's great and what'd you do uh you
said you know you bought a house
uh what what's the mindset so you go
from basically
before that how much money did you have
because you were just paying yourself a
salary out of the business
right like you didn't sound like you had
you were at serious selling tvs it's not
like you had a bunch of money before
that
you're running the business you're
probably paying yourself some salary but
probably nothing fancy and then all of a
sudden you come into a bunch of money so
describe that transition and what you
did what you did with it
yeah so i i was okay before
the acquisition i i was buying ethereum
at like 20.
i remember like the day ethereum came on
the coinbase
and the etf was coming out like approval
denial
and i was like bitcoins going down let's
just move it into this new thing called
ethereum so i bought a bunch of ethereum
so
i had like let's just call like you know
high six figures
so i wasn't like paying debt you know as
soon as we got acquired but
right when you go through an acquisition
you have a closing date
and we had a circle closing date and
then all of a sudden this gigantic
amount of money just hits your bank
account and you're like what the [__]
did i just
do that was my feeling i was actually
kind of scared i was like
is this legal like did i just sell drugs
like
that like you know some people like
think like you just celebrate and you're
like
like i i made it like yeah so i was like
the opposite i was like
you know kindly i was like chain smoking
like a jewel i was like
oh holy [__] this is insane
you know because you know i grew up poor
like you know
my dad died when i was six i grew up in
detroit
i moved to san clemente when i was you
know
like five i grew up knowing
like what it's like to like really
struggle for money so
going from like that to like an
absorbent amount where
you know i'm not flying private or
anything like that like i'm not
like balling like some other people you
guys talk to but
i'm comfortable like i was seth like i
can literally
buy a house cash i could you know put
money into something really boring and
just
you know watch it grow over time so it
was a life-changing moment but
my reaction was holy [__]
this is insane and i hope
you know they don't come back and say
hey
we found something wrong yeah
and the business when i did my deal when
we did my deal i remember i called the
bank ahead of time and
i let them know i'm like there's going
to be like a big deposit and i don't
want you to think that like i'm doing
something illegal
like is there like a check mark you need
to put next to this like
i called you i told you like this is
normal and
they're like no like it's fine and
they're like how much
do you expect to come in and i remember
being on the phone i like i whispered it
i was like i didn't want anyone to hear
i'm like
it's like uh around this number and
they're like i can't hear you and i
remember saying it again
and i had and i whispered a little bit
more and and
i i it was uncomfortable i was like this
is kind of weird
uh saying this and they're like yeah
that shouldn't be a problem at all and
i'm like
well you you don't sound impressed like
yeah
sam i i i did this thing for a minute um
so the the first thing i did was um i
hired a wealth manager to move all the
money out of
my bank account he just bought bonds i
knew nothing about bonds and then all of
a sudden i'm like why is there more
money and they're like yeah
that's how bonds used to work at least
um but when i went in to wire the money
so my office was in la jolla in san
diego it's kind of like the beverly
hills of san diego
um the guy was like this is the biggest
wire i have
ever done like can we triple triple
triple triple
quadruple check this and i was like
really like la jolla like there's like
10 million dollar houses everywhere it's
like yeah this is the biggest one
like i'm nervous and so we wired that
over it's a lot of money
but what i used to do i i was i was just
gonna say one other funny thing i do
i would go in i this is kind of like a
like a lame move but i used to go into
the bank a few times before that wire
and i'd pull out like a 20 bill i'd be
like hey can i get like 20 bucks out
just so they can see my account like
like yeah i just need 20 bucks and then
they look they and i come in looking
like this i'm like 29
because i was 29 when i sold the
business so like
you know i'm gonna do some immature
stuff like i'm not gonna
be a professional like you know and i i
i
um you know i i hadn't been married i
didn't have a kid at the time so
you know it it it was party time at that
at that moment
um so yeah i'd go into the bank and be
like hey were you like
i was gonna say similarly we had uh this
guy james hong who created hot or not on
the podcast he said the same thing he
goes
i used to go to an atm machine and just
put my card in and say print balance
and just look at it and he's like i
would just do that like every day for
like the first
like in know week that that it happened
and just he just wanted to print out the
balance on his little paper rip it up
and then like go about his day he just
made him happy so on this podcast we've
had a lot of really
we've had a lot of really successful
people we've had some people who have
sold things for over a billion dollars
we've had people who have sold things
for hundreds of millions of dollars
we've had people who have raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
this is all a huge amount of money but i
have found myself
when we talked to these incredibly we
just had darmesh on the podcast and i
was like dumbass isn't it crazy i could
see your
lick your hubspot shares you know right
now you're worth like 900 million
dollars that's wild
and um so you kind of like get in this
bubble of like oh yeah it's like
you know uh 20 10 million whatever 30
million whatever the numbers are
we're like oh that's like you know
that's a nice start you know but then
like
when you when you think about one person
having that amount of money particularly
when they're young when they're 29
um that's it that's a that i ran the
math here they had a friend that sold
his company and he's uh
32 now and he's got over 50 million
dollars liquid and i was like
dude this is crazy that you have this
and we did some research and we found
out that there's like 600 americans
uh who have that much money or more who
are also
around that same age it's like dude
that's crazy you're like one of the
you know almost top 500 richest young
people in america that's a
an astounding amount of money and that's
kind of like what you had andrew it it's
an astounding thing
and you talk about like well i can't
play private uh you can't fly private
but it's like
yeah yeah yeah you can you really can i
mean you're like incredibly wealthy if
you have that amount of money at a at
that young of an age the age factor is a
really big deal here
i i agree because i mean so
moving in do you guys want to hear what
i bought i told you i'd share it
so the first thing my friends call me
kind of like um
like like a white rapper kind of guy
like i love hip hop
like i love fast cars i love big houses
yeah detroit man if it wasn't eminem
it'd be me um
so i bought a big-ass house cash um
2.5 million uh san mateo right on the
golf course
i see like literally deers running
around in my backyard
um and i recommended that to you sam
cause it's like it's
you work so hard and when you come from
nothing
just having i wanted something that i
could just be proud of like you come
over and you're like
damn you don't get this with a regular
job and i'm like
yeah you don't you need to start a
business and i'm happy to talk to you
about that because that's like all i
talk about is
startups and stuff like that um and then
also for my wife just for
you know supporting me through the years
and you know we wanted to start a family
so
um bought a beautiful home uh
and then i bought a c63 amg
like you sam but i bought a older one
for
the yeah badass car uh for the naturally
aspirated end it was my second one
um i wanted just like a newer one with
less miles
um and that's that's all i bought um
that's pretty that's pretty much it just
and then i put the rest
into uh just like really boring index
funds like vanguard dimensional
um i don't i barely angel the
yes i got a black mercedes uh black amg
mercedes i think
technically mine is faster than yours
just
but i looked i looked it up oh my god
but they're both
cool they're both cool i got a house i
didn't get nearly as fancy but a nice
house
and then i also put almost every single
thing into a vanguard total
market index fund and sean and a few
other people just
mercilessly like kind of kind of mock me
like
if they don't mock me like sean kind of
rolls his eyes he's like why aren't you
taking risks and i'm like i don't know
this seems pretty risky
so you and i are the same uh same type
of thing i don't know why
shawn and all these guys we hang out
with i don't know why they like buy
stocks all the time i'm like what are
you doing
like what i don't even know how to like
what do you mean dude it's fun it's the
real world casino uh you know like
whatever
you got to have some fun with it i've
never sold a stock and i don't
and these guys are doing it like every
day sharing their screenshots and i'm
like you're nuts
i think that's nutty
i i guess i guess my view is like
what what more money do you need like
the way i view it and if you do the math
like you know 10 marker returns
compounded for
40 years sell when you're 70 you're set
like you're going to be
bawling when you're seven you're going
to be like rich
like like you're going to die with that
money and so
like for me i don't like checking the
stock market i don't care to
i don't want to understand it um i no
longer own
any bitcoin or ethereum like i have the
most
boring investment strategy so people
listening to this that are like
in real estate or you know stocks or
probably like
this kid's an idiot but i like waking up
without
any money problems i don't have a
mortgage i don't
care if my stock portfolio goes down
like it's just there until i'm 70 it's a
set plan
i'm not deviating from it but i guess
for me money buys
like just peace of mind like i just i
have no worries
and so you know tying in the micro choir
it's like
i'm comfortable taking big swings
because you know i have
a win under my belt um comfortable with
everything i have
i have no material wants it outside the
lamborghini uh
urus i'd take that if i could afford it
or actually get it approved by my wife
um who's a
very very uh cost uh
conscientious italian um
but other than that i mean you know just
love building businesses
and that's all i focus on and that's i
think that's the key sam is like you
know
when you go boring it allows you to
focus on what you're really really good
at rather than trying to like
manage stocks like investing in startups
like what's crypto doing today
like who's this new i don't know
whatever yeah it's it's like zuckerberg
zuckerberg wearing the same gray shirt
every day he just removed one whole
thing he needs to think about which is
like fashion how i look what i'm gonna
wear or how i'm gonna dress that day and
just lets his brain focus on the one
thing he wants it to focus on
that day so
i wanted to ask you i want to wrap this
up because uh we're gonna basically use
this as like kind of half the episode
than half the episode's gonna be a
different
riff but i wanted to ask you because
you're seeing a bunch of businesses on
mic require every day
what um you know this is the podcast of
business ideas
what ideas or niches or spaces are you
seeing interesting things give us
two or three ideas that people should be
looking at
or spaces that people could be building
in that you see opportunity
um that you would do if you were kind of
like you know 22 again or whatever
yeah definitely well first i'm going to
take the cop out answer and i would
start with something you're passionate
in i think that's huge
like if you're not passionate about it
there's someone who is and they're gonna
just
beat you but i think what's really
opened my eyes about microchoir every
day i wake up and i get to see the most
interesting
startups i was telling um someone
earlier today like
there was a rabbit breeding company for
farmers to track
like when they make other rabbits or
something like that make like a million
a year or something like that
like super niche and profitable and i'm
like and it's a sas
business it's legit um
probably not like the bet i would not
recommend buying that business it's not
for me
but it just is an example of just how
broad i think the future of of the small
business economy is going to be online
digital and profitable people who used
to want to start like a restaurant
or like a plumbing business or something
like that those young entrepreneurs are
going to be looking to start a niche
sas company or a niche e-commerce
company like categories that we see
a lot of activity in are obviously
shopify sas
applications lots of communities even
newsletters
like kind of everything online and
like it goes as deep as like we sold
this
company that was a marketing automation
platform for
just specific types of dentists and they
were making
an absorbent amount of profit sold
within like a couple weeks
but that's kind of where i think things
are going is we're going to have a few
really really large companies you know
ventures going in
to you know tons of tons of different
companies and we're going to see just
probably a handful of winners is my
guess and then we're going to see a long
tail and the tan
calculating that someone put this out
where
um you know you have a 2.5 chance of
becoming a unicorn when you raise
venture capital
so those are my odds i'd probably
increase it to 20
just with my my luck my friends call me
gazlock
that's another nickname i have um but
for the other 97.5 percent there's
microacquire
you know if you build a business and you
know you want to sell for
you know a small but life-changing
amount you're not getting a tech wrench
you can do that but
yeah trends just very very
niche very very focused i think is the
key
and those are the businesses i get most
excited about and then if you're looking
to buy a business
there's a ton that just are built
by really really talented engineers
great for acquirers i'm seeing tons of
those
and then also for people that are
experiencing sales and marketing you
want to just
like we did with dan shawn where we just
let's hustle on this thing and try to
grow it that's also
a huge opportunity let's name a few
specific ones you have this one
started by this guy named arson
nurmagomedov i know how to say that last
name because
khabib khabib khabib nurmagomedov i
didn't realize that that was a common
last name
um but so this is a b2b saw or can you
actually talk about this i'm looking at
the email
a b2b software company corporate gifting
i don't even know what that is
20 million in arr 3 million in profit it
looks like
right am i reading this right yep yeah
so all those are private so i can't name
the names the one that
what you're viewing at the top is a
podcast that i did so
um arson sold rest pack for half a
million on micro require in about a
month
i believe it was like a developer api
tool there's over a thousand plus
startups on my require right now so i
i don't have my i'm not that smart my
memory is not that good
but uh keep going yeah no i just oh i i
i'm looking at one of the ones you had
listed here on this idea sheet i guess
so that one wasn't one that you sold so
i just want to hear about a specific one
a
a few specific ones that you've sold as
well as like maybe a few specific ones
where you saw this you're like oh my
gosh
i could have i should have started this
company or like this is amazing i i
if people knew that these types of
things they existed they would totally
be starting things like this
okay so i'll talk about the ones that i
know i have permission
to talk about one um was a company
called
uh push engage it sold to um
an individual named sied he runs a firm
called also motive
and he basically is doing a wordpress
type
roll-up and he looks for yeah
we've talked about we've talked about
wpbeginner on here a bunch
so it's yeah awesome guy that
acquisition was in the seven figures
that went closer than like
she had moved fast i don't close in like
two weeks or something like that i don't
i don't know the exact details but
um the founder was happy ced was happy
um
another one would be median which sold
for a quarter million 300
i don't know the exact amount of the
time i had but it's basically like a
live chat
video tool so if you log on to a website
instead of going to like crisp chat like
this intercom button i'm seeing right
here
you can just click it and then like my
video pops up and you're like hey
like and then i can take control of your
this was probably my favorite business
because you can
you know add it for sales teams support
teams and anytime someone has
any questions and it was they had really
really large enterprise agreements with
some big big names
that i can't say because they're under
nda but
public companies that you would
recognize and
that one was interesting another one
the marketing automation platform for
dentists that one sold really fast
um i did another one with um
a company called xmark clock which is
like a time management solution for
construction workers
and the guy was based in europe and he
sold for
over half a million again in less than
30 days
um all cash transaction i'm just trying
to think of the podcast that i've done
there i mean there's so there's so many
so it sounds to me like
i think what people should do is if you
end up going on micro choir i've done
this
in a couple of different platforms uh
basically you can learn a lot just by
checking out the different businesses so
even if you're not ready to buy
uh get the premium subscription or
whatever so you can read the like actual
details about the businesses
and that's like a you know like a 300
mba that you can give yourself because
you're going to discover all these
different niches the patterns you're
gonna see which businesses sell for more
which businesses sell quickly and it'll
really shape your thinking so that's
kind of my recommendation
whether if you're buying obviously you
know it's a no-brainer but even if
you're not buying i think this is a
great way to learn i've done this i've
looked at probably
200 online businesses for sale just
with the only intention of like learning
yeah and um
and that's that's how my brain just sort
of collects a bunch of data so i would
recommend doing that
um but we should we should wrap it here
because we're gonna have to do one more
segment after this but uh
andrew thanks for coming on man thanks
uh best of luck with mark require
excited to to be on board with this
thing and uh
yeah thanks for thanks for sharing the
story i think people are gonna dig it
yeah i appreciate you guys having me on
and uh yeah zillow for m a coming up
appreciate you guys uh
supporting sweet thank you
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
let's travel never looking back